good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director at the long now
foundation thank you all for making it
out tonight and squeezing in looks like
I think we let everybody in from the
outside line thank you
as many of you know that before we do
these talks we have a tradition called
the long short a short film that
exemplifies long-term thinking we try
and theme these four the evenings talk
and for this evening Austin and our
office found this wonderful one that was
done for a radio lab episode called
words and it is about the interpretation
of words and it has no words in it enjoy
[Music]
here in the pension
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll run away I'm serious I'm gonna run
away
[Music]
that's not gonna fly
[Music]
light as a feather come on light as a
feather
like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you
good evening I'm Stu
brand from the long now foundation long
now was surprised by getting interested
in languages our rosetta project really
was just a idea to figure out something
would be fun to show in a non digital
preservation format but once we
discovered that nobody had actually
collected all of the documented
languages in the world in one place we
started to get into it and now person in
charge of rosetta is laura welter
linguist by training and we are finding
ourselves keep getting involved with
with language we had Dan ever head up
here a couple of months ago who had
spent time with the pair AHA and Amazon
and he threw out Noam Chomsky's approach
to linguistics because it didn't fit
with what he saw on the field our next
speaker says that all anthropologists
have this experience please welcome
someone coming from psychology to
linguistics leverage its key
thank you very much for having me it's a
real pleasure to be able to speak to
this crowd the home the home crowd I
study how the languages that we speak
shape the way we think and all
discussion of this question starts with
a basic observation that languages
really differ from one another in what
they require of their speakers so let's
start with a hypothetical example
suppose you want to say this you know
it's hypothetical let's just focus on
the verb if you were to say this in
English and this is something that
happened in the past then you have to
mark that on the verb so you have to say
red instead of will read or reads or is
reading and so on so you have to include
information about tense now in some
languages you wouldn't change the verb
in fact you couldn't change the verb to
mark tense so in Indonesian for example
the verb would always say the same in
some languages not only would you have
to change the verb to mark tense but
you'd have to figure out how long ago in
the past the event happens so for
example in me on Papua New Guinean
language there are five different past
tenses so depending on whether something
happened just now or within the last two
weeks or within a month or within a year
and so on
you would have to use a different past
tense in some languages like in Russian
my native language you'd have to mark
tense but you'd also have to include on
the verb the gender of the reader so if
it was Todd Palin that did the reading
you'd use a different form of the verb
than if it was Sara in Russian also you
have to change the verb depending on
whether the event was completed or not
in some sense so if Sara read the whole
thing from cover to cover assiduously
that would be one form of the verb but
if she skimmed it or if she just started
it and put it down that would be a
different form of the verb in Russian
you also have to do this in the future
tense which is very inconvenient when
you're
say to someone oh I'll read your thesis
tomorrow you really have to commit to
whether you're gonna read the whole
thing in some languages like in Turkish
you have to change the verb depending on
how you came to know about this
information so if you witness this
miraculous event with your own eyes that
would be one form of the verb but if you
just heard about it from someone or
maybe it's something you inferred from
something that she said that would be a
different form of the verb and again
some languages make many such
distinctions that if you know something
from hearing as opposed to from sight as
opposed to inferring it from hearing as
opposed to inferring it from sight you'd
use all these different forms of the
verb so on the one hand when people have
looked at such differences they said wow
languages really require very different
things of their speakers it must be the
case that speakers of different
languages see the world differently just
in order to be able to speak the
language grammatically they have to pay
attention to very different things on
the other side people have argued you
know not so fast just because people
talk differently doesn't necessarily
mean they think differently maybe
everyone notices all of these different
things and just depending on the
language that you speak you happen to
include one bit of information or
another bit of information but it
doesn't really mean that you don't know
all the other stuff yep
linguistic expressions are always very
sparse only we are only ever saying a
very small proportion to what we
actually know so it could be that
everyone actually knows and pays
attention to all this stuff
logically that would mean that all
speakers of all languages would have to
pay attention to an encode all of the
distinctions that are encoded in all of
the world's languages that's a big
potentially very big set of stuff but
it's not impossible
so that's the debate and the question of
whether language shapes thought is not
really just one question it's lots of
interesting questions that we can ask
for example you could ask do people who
speak different languages think
differently does learning new languages
shape the way you think so if you take a
French class or a Japanese class are you
just learning a new way of talking
are you actually learning a new way of
thinking a new way of
seeing the world do polyglots people who
speak lots of languages do they think
differently depending on the language
that they're speaking in the moment some
people some bilingual is a report that
they're actually they feel like they're
different people so they say when I'm
speaking Spanish I feel like I have a
different personality like I'm a
different person than when I'm speaking
English are some thoughts unthinkable
without language if your language
doesn't have a particular property or if
you haven't learned that particular
property yet would are there some things
that are impossible for you to conceive
and ultimately what is basic what is
universal in human cognition
how do languages and cultures allow us
to become as smart and as sophisticated
as we are and is there
intrinsic value in all this linguistic
diversity they're about 7,000 languages
in the world and they all differ from
one another in innumerable ways is there
value in that okay now people have been
expressing opinions on this topic for a
very very long time so here for example
Charlotte Hmong Holy Roman Emperor he
says to have a second language is to
have a second soul that's a very strong
statement about the value of a language
one of his successors says a man who
knows four languages is fourth is worth
four men again another very strong
statement another successor Frederick
the Great of Prussia had a more specific
set of hypotheses he says I speak
English to my accountants French to my
ambassador's Italian to my mistress
Latin to my god in German to my horse
not sure how he came up with this
particular set but these are the kinds
of things that people have been positing
for a long time maybe German is better
for reason or maybe French is better for
love or maybe Hebrews better for oratory
there isn't any empirical evidence for
any of these huge overarching hypotheses
but we'll talk about more specific
hypotheses now of course these guys had
a lot of clout not not everyone has been
in love with this idea so here is Jerry
Fodor he's a philosopher of mind
and he says I hate relativism more than
I hate anything else excepting maybe
fiberglass powerboats he's a sailor so
he doesn't he doesn't like all the noise
and wake of those boats but beyond those
boats the real bane of his existence is
this idea that language might shape the
way people think and his view really
expresses what cognitive science and
philosophy of mind and linguistics had
come around to over the last few decades
people really became disenchanted with
this idea that language might shape the
way we think and partially because
there's so little evidence of these
kinds of effects so what I want to do
today is show you some of the new
evidence that we have okay so the
question we have is do the structures of
particular languages shape the way we
attend to encode represent remember and
reason about the world okay and here's
the outline for the talk I'll talk about
roughly four different ways that
language can shape thought these are
four ways that I think are interesting
the first one is whether language can
have deeper early effects on cognition
the next one is whether language can
have broad or pervasive effects I'll
explain these later whether they're big
differences as a function of cross
linguistic differences and whether
they're important real-world
consequences so start let's start with
deep early effects what do I mean by
this what I mean is there are some cross
linguistic differences that can change
how you perceive the world so even the
very basics of perceptual processing
things processes that are very very
early in the cognitive stream might be
affected by language now if you can show
that something like that takes place
that means that everything down
downstream everything past that early
perceptual process will be affected as
well
and that's very exciting right because
we're getting a huge amount of
information from the world and we can't
possibly process all of it so we have to
throw a lot of information away and so
if it's the case that speakers of
different languages are throwing out
different parts of their perceptual
information
once you throw out information early on
in the perceptual processing stream it's
gone you can't get it back so that's one
reason that people have been very
excited to look for early effects in
cognition and one classic domain to look
is in the perception of color so
languages divide up the color spectrum
in many many different ways some
languages have only two words for colors
some have lots and lots of words and
here's an example these colors don't
look exactly right but just take my word
for it
so in English there's a category blue
that covers let's pretend all of the
colors on the screen there are here but
in Russian there isn't a single word for
blue there are instead two different
words you have to make a distinction
between light blues gala boy and dark
blues see me so that means that Russian
speakers have to call these two colors
by different names does that mean that
Russian speakers actually see those
colors as being more different from one
another would it be easier for them to
distinguish these two colors so here's a
really simple task people are showing
three patches of color the color on top
is identical to one of the colors on the
bottom can you all tell which one left
right and so in the task that's all
you'd have to do is you'd have to press
a button either on the left or on the
right to say which one is identical very
simple task you don't have to be very
smart to do this task if you were a
pidgin you could do this task
right this is so you don't need language
for this task the question is does does
the fact that you make a distinction in
your language actually change how
quickly and how well you can do this
task so the task is set up this way on
some trials the distractor color the
color that you're not going to choose
comes from a different linguistic
category in Russian then the two colors
they're identical and on other trials it
comes from the same linguistic category
so for a Russian speaker this kind of
trial on your left should be easier than
the trial on the right for an English
speaker of course they're all blue right
there's no distinction
so both kinds of trial
should be equally equally fast of course
the words never appear on the colors
they're just there for your your
convenience now when we started doing
this study we did it because I thought
it wasn't going to work and I thought it
would be a really good way to place some
limits on how far a language can reach
into the cognitive system but there are
two surprises coming my way the first
surprise is there is actually a
difference between Russian and English
speakers in how they were able to do
this task Russian speakers were faster
on these kinds of trials than on these
kinds of trials whereas English speakers
showed no difference even though they
were looking at all the same colors that
the Russian speakers were looking at
there's nothing in the nature of the
colors that was different they actually
were performing the task differently the
second surprise was that when we took
people's ability to use language in the
task away so as people were doing this
task we made them repeat numbers to
themselves and this kind of wipes out
your ability to to access your
linguistic knowledge fluently when we
did that that took away the cross
linguistic difference now Russian
speakers and English speakers look the
same now that suggested to us that it
was really language meddling in this
very low-level perceptual task that we
never would have thought language would
be reaching into and now that was a big
surprise so that suggests that language
can actually reach in into these very
early perceptual processes and change
how we how we process even the
perceptual world okay so that's color
what about something more broad
something something that applies to
maybe more more different categories in
the world here here's an example the
broader pervasive kinds of effects
usually come from grammatical
differences so in lots of languages
there are grammatical gender systems
where all nouns are assigned into one
gender another so masculine or feminine
for example in Spanish how many people
here speak a line
which of grammatical genders just so I
have a sense okay so Oh almost all of
you know what I'm talking about okay and
it can be really frustrate you know you
it can be really frustrating to learn in
a language with grammatical gender David
Sedaris has this wonderful essay about
how he was frustrated by learning French
grammatical gender so much so that he
decided to refer to everything in the
plural so he would get two toasters and
two tomatoes and two blenders and
because then he wouldn't have to
remember the grammatical genders of
anything so one thing that's very
convenient about about grammatical
genders is they differ from language to
language so for example the word for the
Sun is feminine and German masculine in
Spanish the word for the moon is
masculine in German feminine in Spanish
does that mean that people actually
German speakers actually think of the
Sun as being more feminine somehow
whereas Spanish speakers think of it as
being more masculine could people
actually take meaning from these
grammatical genders let me just show you
an example of how pervasive grammatical
gender marking can be in a language that
has a grammatical gender so this is an
example from Russian so in Russian words
that have different grammatical genders
have different phonological properties
they'll sound different you use
different number words so the word for
one will be different depending on
whether it's one masculine something or
feminine something you get different
adjective endings different pronouns and
possessive and even different verb
endings so circled in red there is one
example if you want to say in Russian my
chair was white the word for chair is
masculine so you use the masculine form
of my then you have the word chair which
is has a masculine sound then you use
the masculine form of was and the
masculine form of white so you've just
marked the masculinity of a chair four
times in four words you don't have a lot
of opportunity to forget what
grammatical gender things are in Russian
a very pervasive feature of language now
what would an effective grammatical
gender actually look like what does it
mean if I say to you do you think of a
chair as masculine or feminine clearly
you're not thinking it has you know
biological properties that are masculine
or feminine what what could it possibly
mean so here's an example
this is Andriy McKean describing an
experience that he had as he was
switching between Russian and in French
spending summers with his grandmother he
says as a child that absorbed all the
sounds of Charlotte's language French I
swam in them without wondering why that
glint in the grass that colored scented
living brilliance sometimes existed in
the masculine and had a crunchy fragile
crystalline identity imposed it seemed
by one of its names so it took that's
the Russian word for flour and it's
masculine and was sometimes undeveloped
in a velvety felt like in feminine aura
becoming in flu which is French for
flower and it's feminine so that's the
kind of effective grammatical gender on
semantics that we're looking for that
something takes on a different kind a
different shape a different shading a
different connotation depending on the
grammatical features that it has in a
language now do normal people have these
kinds of associations or just sensitive
young men learning French from their
grandmother's so here are some examples
from the empirical literature people
people who are not poets showing this
kind of effect Russian speakers this is
a study done in 1915 an old study
Russian speakers at Moscow State
University were asked to personify days
of the week so act like Monday or act
like Wednesday or act like Tuesday now
these days of the week have different
grammatical genders so Monday is
masculine but Wednesday is feminine and
what the researchers noticed this is a
study by Roman Jakob s'en when he
noticed that was people were acting out
as if these days of the week actually
had genders they act like a man for
Monday but like a woman for Wednesday in
another study young kids
spanish-speaking kids were asked we're
making an animated movie and here all
the characters and there might have been
a clock and there might have been a fox
and there might have been a pencil or
something like that what voices should
we give to these characters and they had
to choose voices and even very young
kids were starting to pick voices that
were congruent with Kermit
gender so the voice they wanted a clock
to have depended on the grammatical
gender in their language in another set
of studies people are asked to describe
objects so you just come into the lab
and you you're told
give me three adjectives that describe a
bridge and people have to give you some
adjectives and the kinds of adjectives
people came up with again we're
congruent with grammatical gender so if
you if it's feminine your language
you're more likely to say beautiful or
elegant or extended whereas if it's
masculine in your language you're more
likely to say things like long and
towering and big enormous and you can
even see these effects with your own
eyes if you go to an art gallery and ask
how do artists decide how to personify
abstract entities in their art so we did
this we looked through a art store which
is a giant art database about 600 years
of artworks that we concentrated on and
we asked for all the personifications
that exist in this art database can we
predict whether time or death or victory
will be masculine or feminine depending
on the grammatical gender in the artists
native language
the answer is 78 percent of the time we
can make a prediction so you know if you
want to make a bet it's a pretty good
bet to to place and these are the kinds
of things you can see for yourself so
for example the Statue of Liberty right
why is Liberty a lady
well she's French she comes and in
French Liberty is feminine or here you
see john ashcroft
and behind him is the statue of justice
that he tried to cover up because she
was so indecent and again you could ask
why is justice a woman well justice is
feminine in Latin that's where that's
where it comes from here are some of my
favorite examples this is Michelangelo
sculpting different parts of the day so
the dawn the day the dusk and the night
and you might ask well why is the dawn a
woman and the day a man and the dusk a
man and the night a woman well those are
the grammatical genders and
this is a wonderful way in which this
little quirk of grammar that we don't
even you know when you speak a language
like this as a native speaker you don't
even notice but it's making its way even
into the physical world that we that we
then live in right and it gets passed
down in these physical ideas that other
other people inherit okay now one reason
to be interested in this funny quirk of
grammatical gender is that the
grammatical gender is so pervasive in
language gender goes on all nouns so if
you can show the grammatical gender
affects how people think that means that
this is a feature of language that is
affecting how people think about
anything that can be named by noun now
think about what are all the things that
can be named by nouns it's a lot of
stuff right so as you look around the
world that's a very very pervasive
affective language okay are there big
differences so grammatical gender maybe
these are small alternations widely
spread but are there any really big
differences for the big differences I
think we need to turn to those parts of
cognition where we really need to
construct the world where the world
doesn't have the structure to give to us
we have to bring the structure to it and
one really good place to look for that
are abstract ideas so take time time is
one of my favorite examples because it's
on the one hand it's extremely popular
so the word time is the most frequent
now and in English and other temporal
words like year and day are also in the
top 10 at least in english-speaking
culture we're obsessed with time but
even though it's so frequent it's uh
it's hard to get your hands on right its
forms the very fabric of our experience
but you can't see it time you can't
touch time you can't smell time why
don't we come up with a mental
representation of this abstract entity
now this idea this question of how do
you come up with mental representations
of abstract things has
haunting people for a really long time
it frustrated Plato for example it
frustrated him so much that he came up
with a very famous philosophical
argument it's called an argument from
the poverty of the stimulus what that
argument was is that information
available in the environment is simply
not enough not structured enough not
complex enough not available enough to
be able to create abstract thought and
so he says I can't see how we could
possibly learn these things and so his
solution is we recall them from past
incarnations of our souls now you may
think ok you know what that's Plato
that's a long time ago what did the
Greeks know anyway Aristotle thought the
brain was a radiator so they didn't even
know thinking happened in the brain why
why should we care well actually quite
modern ideas about where concepts come
from share some of these very properties
so here for example is Noam Chomsky from
2000 he says even words such as
carburetor and bureaucrat in fact pose
the familiar problem of poverty of the
stimulus however surprising the
conclusion may be that nature has
provided us with an innate stock of
concepts and that the child's task is to
discover their labels there appear to be
few other possibilities now I'd like to
think that there must be another
possibility not this is a very wouldn't
it be a really exciting though if you
actually were born with the idea of
carburetor or a bureaucrat already in
that would be awesome right but given
that I don't know what a carburetor is
now that seems unlikely
so let's let's look for some other
answers so what would be another answer
well here's a story how do we come up
with an idea like time travel that's a
fancy notion that we have it's probably
not through personal experience through
time travel right it's not because you
actually went and traveled to another
time and came back and you stored away
that experience but here's a story
across languages people use spatial
language spatial words to talk about
time so
say things like we're approaching the
holidays we're coming up on Christmas
we're coming up to the deadline and so
on now that metaphor lays out a metaphor
and analogy where time is a path and
you're traveling on it right well once
you have that analogy in place so time
is a path and you're traveling on it
well on a regular path you can travel in
any direction you want and whatever
speed you want so once you have that
analogy in place it allows the
possibility of time travel you can now
create that idea very easily so what's
what kind of evidence could we have that
this kind of way of building knowledge
actually is possible or something that
people do well so one question you could
ask is it the case that people build
knowledge of time out of knowledge of
space and the other is do patterns and
language and culture actually encourage
how people encourage different ways of
using space for thinking about time
those are the two ingredients of the
time travel story I just gave you one is
you have to have patterns and language
that encourage an analogy and the other
is that you are reusing spatial
knowledge some how to think about time
let me give you just a couple of brief
data points I'm gonna pick the coolest
ones that I that I have but if you have
more detailed questions I'd love to hear
them okay now one way this is a good
demonstration of how I stay oriented one
way to test the idea that the way people
think about time is based on how they
think about space is to find cultures
that have different ways of thinking
about space and see if they also have
different ways of thinking about time so
to demonstrate the difference why don't
we all do this one thing what I'm going
to ask all of you to close your eyes and
I can sort of see you so I can tell
whether or not you've closed your eyes
okay now everyone points southeast
okay no no cheating okay you can open
your eyes I see points there there there
there there I don't know which way it is
you guys are gonna have to figure it out
later
let me make a few observations about
what you did is a cognitive psychologist
first there's a really low compliance
rate a lot of you just did not point we
would we would have to throw you out of
the subject pool second there is a
really long reaction time for a lot of
you took a long time to point and
perhaps most importantly the accuracy
wasn't very high now I don't need to
know which way it is to know that
because you guys pointed in every
possible direction now there are some
places where asking a question like that
would yield immediate correct responses
from everyone including people who are
five years old right so I don't feel bad
you don't want to ask folks at Stanford
or Harvard or MIT they do exactly the
same thing that you guys did it's just
not something that we keep track of so
what are these cultures that keep track
of where they are all the time so here's
an example of a culture I had a chance
to work with these are the cooked I or
they're an aboriginal group in Australia
and what's cool about their language is
they don't use words like left and right
to divide up space instead everything is
expressed in terms of north south east
and west and by everything I mean
everything at all scales so you say
things like there's a dog trying to bite
your east leg can you move your cub to
the north-northwest a little bit the boy
standing south of Mary is my brother at
every scale in order to speak a language
like this you must stay oriented because
your don't just have to stay oriented to
describe your experiences in the moment
you have to remember also which way are
you oriented to be able to describe any
past experiences right so you have to be
able to say things like oh I must have
left my glasses to the
west of the telephone how silly of me
right or after a dinner party you come
home you say oh they set their salad
forks to the southeast of the dinner
forks the Philistines right so even to
even to say hello so the way you say
hello and Kruk Tyler is in English we
say how are you fine in cook tyre you
say which way are you going and the
answer should be something like
north-northeast and the far distance how
about you that is literally to get past
hello you have to know which way you're
going so imagine in your normal daily
lives as you're walking around your
office or you're walking around wherever
it is you are every person who says hi
to you you have to report your heading
direction right you'd get oriented
pretty quick right otherwise you'd be
excluded out of all social interactions
as you couldn't say hello to people
properly so people who speak languages
like this there are a lot of languages
like this around the world people who
speak languages like this do have a
great sense of direction they are able
to perform feats of navigation that we
used to think were beyond human ability
so we knew for a long time that animals
different kinds of animals had
orientation abilities that seemed to
surpass human orientation abilities so
for example we'd say oh ants they stay
oriented pretty well they can Det reckon
but they use a trick they count steps so
it doesn't count or birds you know they
stay oriented but they have magnets in
their beaks so you know takes us off the
hook well turns out there are people in
the world who just stay oriented by
paying attention to where they're going
at all times because they have to in
order to be able to speak their language
grammatically so we don't have any
excuses you don't need to have them
magnets in your beaks to do it and this
great sense of direction is seen in all
kinds of cultural practices in art so
the art that people produce in these
cultures is always done from a bird's
eye view it's laid out on the ground and
the appropriate orientation and so on so
what I wanted to find out is remember
we're thinking about how people think
about time
and the question is if you think about
space differently do does that also mean
you think about other things differently
like do you also think about time
differently so here's a task I give
people a set of pictures like this these
happen to be pictures of my grandfather
in different ages scramble them up I
give them to you and I say lay these out
on the ground so that they're in the
correct order well here they're
displayed in the correct order as as
English speakers perceive the correct
order from left to right that's the way
time goes for us now of course this
left-to-right order relates to writing
direction right there's nothing
intrinsically left to write about time
and there are wonderful examples from
the history of advertising where Nestle
for example have this logo this is part
of their nutritional supplement for Kids
program and whenever they tried this out
and say an arabic-speaking country they
ran into some problems because if you
read this from right to left it's not
clear what this product does for your
child so they had to they had to rethink
their approach and indeed when people
are asked to lay out think things in
temporal order English speakers will lay
things out like this whereas Hebrew
speakers will go in the other direction
and there's even a really fun finding
where for any sentence you ask people
imagine Bill is giving flowers to Susie
draw that out well English speakers will
draw that out with Bill on the left and
Susie on the right but Arabic speakers
will draw it out with Bill on the right
and Susie on the left so why is it that
when we imagine an action it seems to go
in the direction of writing it's kind of
a cool cool finding that all the actions
that you imagine have this perceptual
order to them okay so back to time the
cook tie or don't use words like left
and right so how will they arrange time
English speakers do it from left to
right Hebrew from right to left what
will they do here's an example person
sorry for my messy field notes here so
here's a person there's a
seated facing south and these numbers
represent the temporal order and these
are a bunch of different picture sets
that they laid out so here everything
goes from left to right here's the same
person on a different day this time
they're facing north and now everything
goes from right to left here's another
person they're facing east and now
everything comes towards them what's the
order the Sun from east to west right
now at first when you look at this
pattern you could you might think wow
there's no order they're just doing it
any which way they don't care if it's
left-to-right right-to-left or whatever
but actually another way to put it is
that it's the English speakers that are
doing it with no order right why don't
we think that time always travels with
us with respect to my body orientation
in the moment time is going this way but
now it's going this way but now it's
going this way very egocentric openness
alright that time it has to turn around
every time I turn around for them time
stays with respect to the landscape
perhaps as it should okay now one reason
to be interested in these kinds of
examples is that they demonstrate a
really big difference in cognitive
cognitive ability between two cultures
most of the English speakers that we
tested on these tasks could not have
done what the cook tyre did because they
simply didn't know which way it was
which so even if they wanted to layout
time from east to west they had no idea
which way East and West were so they
couldn't do it and those who didn't know
which way East and West were would never
have thought to do it this way it's just
not the way we organize our world we
organized it with respect to us as
opposed to with respect to the landscape
and I think this shows that there are
some cross linguistic differences that
are not just a matter of degree that one
group does it more or less this way or
another way they're just qualitatively
different ways of organizing the world
that people have and that for me this is
the very exciting thing is discovering
these other ways that you could organize
the world other ways that you could see
the world it's right there and it's
almost like you get to inhabit another
universe another parallel universe just
by
discovering a different way of seeing
the world okay so we've been talking
about how people think about time and
I've given you two examples so far of
what makes a difference and how people
think about time one is how people think
about space so if you find groups that
think about space differently they'll
think about time different things but
the other one was about cultural
artifacts like writing direction that
also seems to matter what about patterns
and language metaphors and language for
time let me give you a few examples from
here it's time horizontal or is it
vertical well here's a study comparing
English and Mandarin speakers in both
English and Mandarin you can use
horizontal terms to organize time but in
Mandarin vertical terms are also quite
frequent so in Mandarin the past is up
and the future is down so the up month
is the last month and the down month is
the next month so does that mean that
Mandarin speakers actually think about
time vertically more more so than
English speakers do so here's a simple
task stand next to someone and you say
if I tell you that this here is today
where would you put yesterday and where
would you put tomorrow a person just has
to point so let me show you an example
this is a dramatic reenactment what
month is this this is May suppose I said
this is May where would you put April
and where are you good June there's
another Mandarin speaker so if I were to
tell you that lunch is right here hmm
where would you say that breakfast is
okay
right there and where would you say that
dinner is
okay so let me show you another another
way to test this that's a little bit
more implicit this is a task you can you
can try for yourself so you're going to
see a picture like this and then you're
going to see another picture that will
represent either an earlier or later
time point so starting from this is it
earlier later later very good good all
right okay some of these are tricky okay
now instead of responding verbally as I
was just asking to do we asked our
participants to respond by pressing
buttons and the buttons could have been
arranged like this where the earlier
buttons on the left and the later
buttons on the right or they could have
been reversed in the opposite direction
from what English speakers like or they
could have been arranged vertically
either with the earlier button on top or
the earlier button on the bottom and the
question was will there be some mapping
that's more natural that English and
Mandarin speakers liked better than
others I feel like we know each other
well enough I can show you a graph first
graph of the talk so on the y axis is
reaction time so up is slower and here
we have English speakers on on the left
and English speakers indeed are
considerably faster when the earlier
button is on the left then when it's on
the right they don't like it when the
earlier buttons on the right but when
the buttons are arranged vertically they
don't care they don't care if the
earlier button is on top or on the
bottom but the Mandarin speakers they
also prefer the earlier button on the
left to on the right but unlike the
English speakers they also have a
preference on the vertical axis they
want the earlier button to be on top
passed earlier past is up they don't
want the earlier baat button to be on
the bottom and
let me just point out that there is an
overall difference the Mandarin speakers
in our sample are a little bit slower
than the English speakers and that's
just because this our English speakers
always Stanford students right so
they're selected to be able to perform
arbitrary tasks very very efficiently
it's very hard to find other people who
are equally selected for especially this
purpose so that's why there's always
going to be a difference like this in
the sample okay now here's another
interesting question what about
bilinguals so for another set of
metaphors rather than asking is time
horizontal or vertical now let's ask
what's moving are you moving in time or
is time coming towards you so in English
both of these things are there both of
these metaphors are available you can
say we're approaching the holidays or
you can say the holidays are approaching
and I'll I'll skip the the full story
that shows that people actually think of
those two scenarios as being very
different even though it's against the
laws of physics to think of them as very
different because in time it shouldn't
there's no fixed ground against which
you're moving so that those two things
shouldn't be different but we treat time
as if it were space as if it had this
extra dimensionality to it but
nonetheless so English speakers use both
of these metaphors quite frequently in
Mandarin most of the time people talk
about time is moving much more rarely do
people talk about themselves as moving
in time and what we find is that so here
this is a an abstracted graph over many
studies what we find is that Mandarin
speakers what I'm showing up is here up
is more likely to think of time as
moving Mandarin monolinguals are more
likely to think of time as moving than
English monolinguals but look at the
groups of bilinguals in the middle so
the Mandarin English bilinguals who were
tested in Mandarin look more like
Mandarin speakers and the ones that are
tested in English so that shows you that
the language that you're being tested in
matters so that gets it that bilingual
question if you're bilingual and you're
thinking for one language or another
does that make a difference the answer
is yes but
look neither of those two groups are
actually looking like the monolinguals
of either language and what that
suggests is that the bilinguals the ones
that are tested in mandarin they're
being affected by having learned English
even though they're not speaking English
at the time and the bilinguals that are
tested in English they're being affected
by having learned Mandarin even though
they're not speaking Mandarin in the
moment so there's both this long-term
effectively having learned a language
that it's affecting you even when you're
not using that language but also this
immediate effect of switching between
two languages where depending on which
language you're speaking you're going to
think a little bit differently that's
kind of a cool way to test it and here
is just another example this is an
example from the Aymara in South America
in I Amara
so in English the future is ahead of us
right all best is ahead of us the worst
is behind us we're looking forward to
the next year and so on in Amara
the future is behind and the past is in
front and in this wonderful study you
Sweetzer and Rafael Nunez looked at how
people gesture when they talk about time
and the Aymara when they're talking
about the past
they gesture towards the front and when
they talk about the future they gesture
towards the back
cool reversal okay so I think in that
domain of time you've seen some pretty
big differences in how people think the
time can completely reverse direction it
can acquire an extra dimension it can go
from east to west as opposed to from
left to right those are some pretty big
differences okay are there are
differences in real-world constant with
real-world consequences now of course in
a in the real world people really care
about what things are called and the way
you know that is that people are
constantly arguing about what things
should be called and they're constantly
trying to change the names of things
right if that didn't if people didn't
think that what things were called
mattered you would never have that kind
of behavior and there's some pretty
striking examples right do you call
someone anti-abortion or pro-life do you
call a government structure regime or in
a
ministration do we call people freedom
fighters or insurgents or terrorists
those are taking very different
perspectives does the US government
sponsor torture or is it just enhanced
interrogation techniques again very
serious consequences is the is it a
government rescue plan or is it a
bailout turns out many more people
support the same program if you call it
a rescue plan than if you call it a
bailout or an older example that bill
and Monica have sex the case for
impeachment stemmed on the definition of
this word in English that's a pretty
serious consequence here's a sillier
example but one I think one that rings
true at some point maybe 10 years ago
the prune board the California prune
Board petitioned the FDA to allow them
to change the name of their product from
prunes to dried plums now just to be
clear prunes and dried plums are the
same thing it's just in case you're
unaware
um now why would they want to do that
obviously it's a good idea because
prunes the word prune they live in a
terrible linguistic neighborhood right
what are prunes neighbors with old age
laxatives right there they remind you of
all kinds of things that young healthy
Californians may not want to be reminded
of when they are shopping for snacks
where's dried plums live in a perfectly
lovely linguistic neighborhood their
neighbors are dried apricots and dried
mangoes and dried kiwi fruits all kinds
of tasty things things you could take on
a hike right so they they figured that
it would be the case that young
Californians would be more interested in
buying dried plums and they were
interested in buying prunes so they cost
the millions of dollars to get get this
change approved and it paid off dried
plums do sell better than prunes
eventually they had to sell prunes and
dried plums side-by-side because some
people actually wanted the laxative
properties of prunes
whereas others wanted the healthy
delicious snack of dried plums and of
course anyone who's travelled knows that
their bizarrely named products being
sold around the world so for example
Pocari sweat is a very popular soft
drink so all around Asia the buyers
there aren't concerned by the
connotations of the word sweat and
something that you drink and there is a
reason I think you can all guess why
this drink hasn't taken off as a big
seller in America and that's because
perhaps advertisers understand that
something named sweat might not taste as
sweet back to more serious matters in
events in the world you know language
requires us to construe events in the
world and even the the the smallest the
shortest instantaneous physical events
require us to come up with some way to
make sense of them so take this example
Dick Cheney goes out hunting he has a
quail quail hunting accident
he accidentally shoots his hunting
partner Whittington in the face now that
said that's a split second event and
there are many many different ways that
we could possibly construe it so this is
one this is from the European Herald and
they said Jane eBags lawyer so Cheney
went out hunting for lawyers and he got
one now um you could say
straightforwardly share Cheney shot
Harry Whittington you could say Harry
Whittington got shot by Cheney you could
say Harry Whittington got shot leave out
Cheney altogether you don't need to
mention it here's what Cheney said this
is when he was taking full
responsibility for the event he said
well ultimately I'm the guy who pulled
the trigger that fired the round that
hit Harry and you can talk about the
other conditions that existed at the
time but that's the bottom line and
there's no it was not Harry's fault
but look it's very kind of him right but
look at that first sentence ultimately
I'm the guy who pulled the trigger that
fired the round that hit Harry a split
second event but now therefore actually
it's a chain of four events and he just
happens to be on one end of those events
are Bush actually did one better look
what he did said he said he heard a bird
flush and he turned and pulled the
trigger
and saw his friend get wounded that is a
masterful exculpation Janey transforms
from agent to mere witness within one
sentence
of course the onion always has the best
headlines they say Whitehouse had prior
knowledge of Cheney threat August
briefing warned Cheney determined to
shoot old man a face with these
descriptions differ on is how much agent
ivities how much cause of power does
Cheney have in the event do we describe
him as the person who caused the outcome
or was he just one end of a long chain
of events that created the outcome was
he even at all involved and languages
give us many many tools to construe
events every event needs to be construed
in some way so in English you could say
John broke the vase or the vase broke
I'm going to call this kind of
construction agentive and the other not
agentive now in Spanish for example you
can also say something like John broke
the vase or the vase broke but in
English it's this kind of construction
the John broke the vase the agentive
construction it's more canonical when
you use non agentive language it sounds
evasive it's a sort of thing that
politicians do or young kids do when
they're trying to get out of having done
something so you know mistakes were made
all of us have favorite non agentive
usages that we've seen in politicians
wears in Spanish it's the not urgent of
construction that's more canonical that
if it was that if something was an
accident
you wouldn't say he broke the vase you
would say the vase broke he would use
this clinic say here to market and
there's this old joke comedian American
comedian and Mexico says oh nothing in
this country's ever anybody's fault it's
all stays fault because you know
whenever whenever something goes wrong
it say something or other say did it now
this property of Spanish actually is
quite common in the world's languages
and English seems to be kind of an
outlier in terms of how agentive we want
our descriptions to be so in English you
can even say things like I broke my arm
a lot lots of languages you can't say
something like I broke my arm unless
you're crazy unless you specifically
went out looking to break your arm and
then you broke it alright it just that
would just be a really bizarre thing to
say so do these kinds of differences in
how languages tend to describe events
actually matter for for example how
people assign blame or how they punish
the agents of events or maybe even for
eyewitness memory here's an example I'm
sorry that's so dark I'll narrate we
showed people videos and the videos
either contained intentional actions or
accidental actions so here's someone
popping a balloon intentionally okay
maybe you were able to see that and hear
the same action also popping a balloon
but this time it's an accident okay so
he happens to move his arm recoils and
surprise first we wanted to find out do
English and Spanish speakers actually
describe these events differently so
here's what English speakers said about
the accidents they said a guy broke his
pencil while trying to write with it he
put his hand down and picked up a sticky
note or he lost a balloon I like this
one a man opens an automatically opening
umbrella the umbrella is already
automatically opening why does someone
have to open it but in English someone
has to open even an automatically
opening umbrella
or or they made personality attributions
the klutzy guy knocked a box off a table
in Spanish the cases looked quite
different so people said things like an
egg that fell on him broke on him or the
pencil broke or he was going to put
something away and the drawer closed
itself the papers stayed itself stuck to
his hand some keys through themselves or
out of nowhere a pencil split itself in
two it's not the sort of thing that ever
happens in English so here's just
showing you the differences in
descriptions in graph form for
intentional actions everyone describes
the events agentive ly but for
accidental actions there's a difference
English speakers are producing more
agentive descriptions than our Spanish
speakers so what about in memory to
people if you're not describing who did
it if you're not paying attention to who
did it
maybe you also don't remember who did it
maybe that wasn't an important part of
the event to pay attention to so we
showed people now a third so at some
point in the task people might have seen
these two guys performing different
actions now we introduce a third
character and he does the action in this
case popping the balloon there he goes
and we ask which of these guys did it
the first time so it's kind of like a
lineup you just have to say can you can
you remember who done it and here's what
we find for intentional actions everyone
remembers who did it pretty well but for
accidental actions well English speakers
still remember who did it really well
where's Spanish speakers remember less
well that's a less important thing to
pay attention to when it's an accident
importantly it's very specific to the
kind to the kinds of descriptions that
you would produce for that event but
very important potential consequences
right and this is just a replication in
Japanese and skip let me give you
another example
does it matter for how much we blame or
punish people in one study we looked at
a whole bunch of court cases so about
two hundred thousand court cases are
heard in London central court and we
asked a simple question if your trial
contains
an agentive expression like broke it are
you more likely to be found guilty than
if your trial contains a non-agenda
expression like it broke and the answer
is yes if if there's a gentle language
in your in the transcript of your court
case you're going to be more likely to
be found guilty we also wanted to find
out how much does it matter how much do
the linguistic descriptions actually
matter so what we did was we showed
people Janet Jackson's wardrobe
malfunction so if you guys probably I
won't show it now because I don't want
to upset the censors but this was an
event where Justin Timberlake and Janet
Jackson were performing at the Superbowl
halftime and for 9/16 of a second Janet
Jackson's breasts was sort of displayed
on national television was a big deal
and Justin Timberlake actually coined
the term wardrobe malfunction as part of
his apology that term didn't exist until
he apologized for the wardrobe
malfunction and now people are having
wardrobe malfunctions all the time so we
showed people the video they saw the
video and we gave them either an agenda
we phrased news report about it or non
agentive ly phrase news report they're
actually the identical report except for
a couple of transitive constructions in
there so and the question is how much
extra do you have to pay for a
transitive right so if you get it if you
got it
if you got nailed with the transitive
construction how much will that cost you
well in Justin Timberlake's case people
wanted 53% more in fines if we said he
ripped the costume as opposed to the
costume ripped that's a pretty hefty
fine for a simple transitive okay so
this is where if you've been let me just
review some of the reasons that I think
the examples I'm showing you are really
about language so you could ask is that
really that language shapes thought or
is it the other way around maybe people
who live in different places think
differently and because of that they
talk differently how do you know which
way the direction of causality goes well
here are some ways that we've tried to
find that out one has been
in language training studies so the idea
is this if language really shapes
thought then you should be able to teach
people a new way of talking and that
should change the way they think right
and that's exactly what these studies
have done and that's exactly what you
find you teach people a new way of
talking and that inadvertently also
changes the way they think another is in
language priming studies so in the case
of eyewitness memory for example what if
you took English speakers and you just
bombarded them with not agentive
language so you kept saying things like
the toast burned and the necklace
unfastened and the paint splattered and
then they had to remember a bunch of
actions would they actually be worse at
remembering who did it after hearing
that kind of Nod agentive language the
answer is yes that if you're surrounded
in the even within an experiment with
non agentive language that changes what
you pay attention to another one is
verbal interference studies so I talked
about this at the very beginning of the
talk when the case of color if you wipe
out people's ability to use language in
in the tasks that often changes how they
think that often changes what they can
do it actually makes us quite stupid to
not be able to use language we don't
realize that we're solving a lot of
tasks linguistically but that's what
we're doing and there are lots of
studies showing that if you wipe out
language in the moment that really
changes what we're capable of and a
final case is bilingual studies so you
take bilinguals and you system when one
language or another to see if the
linguistic context that the immediate
linguistic context makes a difference
and you saw an example of that that it
matters whether you're tested in one
language or another and the other way to
find out is to compare the bilinguals to
monolinguals and see if having learned
another language at some point in your
past makes a difference and the answer
to that is also yes so these are some of
the ways to establish that causality
that language actually plays a causal
role it is of course the case that the
influence also goes the other way
languages are tools that we create for
our purposes right they're tools that
suit our cognitive needs so it isn't
just that language shapes thought it's
also that differences in thought
differences in language goes both ways
okay so some things we've learned people
who speak different languages think
differently there are many different
aspects of language that can shape
thinking from grammar and lexical
differences even to orthography how
language is written language metals and
even low-level perceptual decisions this
was quite surprising to me learning new
languages can change the way you think
and we see this in the bilingual studies
people who've learned another language
aren't just learning a new way of
expressing their thoughts they're
inadvertently actually changing what
thoughts they wish to express based on
based on the languages that they're
learning sometimes people do think
differently depending on the language
that they're being tested in in
bilingual as both languages or however
many languages you know are active to
some extent when you're thinking even
when you're not using that language so
there's a long term effect of having
learned a language one example I didn't
get to show you is that learning a new
language can even change the way you
speak your native language so we saw
this with Indonesian English bilinguals
in Indonesian you don't have to mark
tense or aspect you don't have to put
temporal information in sentences if you
don't want to it's optional but
Indonesians who have learned English
English requires this it enforces it in
every sentence Indonesians have learned
English start putting more temporal
information in there Indonesian so
they're actually changing the way they
speak their native language based on
this other language that they've learned
and finally each language provides us
with its own cognitive toolkit it
encapsulates the knowledge and worldview
that's been developed over thousands of
years in a culture an incredibly rich
knowledge system that lives within each
linguistic system ok so I hope I've
shown you at least a little bit of
evidence suggesting that languages
really shape how we construct reality
and they help make us as smart and
sophisticated as we are there's one
thing that I do agree with Noam Chomsky
on he says when we study human language
we're approaching what some might call
the human essence the distinctive
qualities of mind that
so far as we know unique to men what I'd
like to suggest is that if we take this
idea that languages really differ from
one another seriously then each of those
languages is creating a somewhat
different human essence a somewhat
different way of being human at some a
different way of seeing the world and
engaging with the world and that could
be a potentially very exciting insight
now you might think okay language
profoundly funny you were telling us it
profoundly fundamentally shapes how we
think but sometimes it just doesn't seem
to work so here's an example people try
to change to effect some linguistic
change and it's just silly right so here
US Congress decides to rename french
fries into freedom fries this is when
France refused to go into the war in
Iraq didn't want to join our Coalition
of the Willing and so this was their way
of getting back at them right well and
that that seems stupid right but this is
not new
so during World War one for example
everything that had a German sounding
name became Liberty something or other
there's a reason that these kinds of
substitutions don't work and it's
because they're based on a wrong theory
about how cognition and language relate
to one another so words that you can
simply replace one for the other in the
language are synonyms right so if two
words can equally go well into any
phrase that means they're they have the
same meaning they're synonyms and so
when you make that kind of replacement
what you're saying is French is
synonymous with freedom right so french
fries are freedom fries french toast is
freedom toast french poodles are freedom
poodles french kissing his freedom
kissing and then you have freedom
manicures well what should we call
France then freedom land and French
would be the language of freedom it's
setting up the wrong kind of mapping so
what I want to suggest is if we
understand really how language and
thought interact in the mind we can even
be nationalistic in a more effective
manner
so if we really want to annoy the French
I say take all the things that the
French hate and call them French that
will really annoy them for example
ketchup becomes French sauce McDonald's
will be the French cafe shorts will be
French pants mimosas will be French
cocktails Disneyland will be France
Americans will be French people the
English language will be called French
that'll get him
thanks very much and these are the folks
in my lab who helped make this all
possible and our funding sources that
also very much help thank you
bring your wondering um let's see let's
put you here okay I'm very excited for
your questions because I've heard my
talk before so this is the new part well
I've got a quick question you made so
much of piling well bilingual whatever
the word is the being bilingual lingual
ISM it's a belief system yes a religion
possibly anyway
you learned Russian first as a child and
then English when you were how old 12
okay that's still pretty young I guess
the question I would have people learn
language a certain way when they're very
young and then a different way in school
or by traveling as an adult does it
matter which comes first in how they
manage their by a linguist I like the
word bilingual
it's because I can't invite lingua ality
without falling off my chair so it
definitely does get harder to learn new
languages as you get older and this is
true for a lot of different reasons that
a lot of people use that as an excuse to
not learn new languages but I have a
different way for you guys to think
about it and that is it's going to be a
lot easier to learn a new language now
than it will be in ten years
so you should start now whenever you
it's no it's not too late it's never too
late but it's definitely a lot easier
now than it ever will be in the future
so you should do it now there definitely
there definitely seems to be differences
in languages that you learn early on
languages that you learn that you use
the most and languages that have you've
just been using are the things that have
the most sway over cognition and this is
actually quite an old set of principles
and cognition so there are kind of three
three things that best predict behavior
and its primacy the thing you learn
first frequency the thing you do most
often and Rhys
see the thing you were just doing and
language seems to be no different from
that that the things you learned first
the things you do most frequently in the
things you were just doing are the
things that hold more sway
you're doing some gestures as you're
saying that and even Tomlinson has a
question and where does gesture come in
she wonders if there have been studies
that look at how the use of hands
emphasized a spoken word is that you
know play out in these different
languages and does it affect how we
thinking stuff like that so speakers of
different languages do gesture
differently and the study of gesture has
just come on the scene in the last
couple of decades it's it's a it's
something that people didn't use to look
at in language at all and there's a
incredibly rich source it's impossible
to talk about with gesture without
paying attention to your own gestures
it's I don't know how gesture
researchers give talks at all and it
must be very hard but one thing that's
interesting about gestures is that we
gesture we of course gesture
communicatively for other people but if
you've ever seen someone talk on the
phone they still gesture right which
means that we're also gesturing for
ourselves that it's it's actually
helping you think and so it has both of
those functions it's not only to explain
something to someone else it's also
helps it helps you retrieve a word if
you ask people to sit on their hands
while they're doing lots of cognitive
tasks for example even saying what words
or words if they slow down we want we
want to be able to have to have our our
hands to gesture if that's what you're
used to doing we have a question from
Holly hello out there you could raise
your hand to take up that theme how
about languages which are primarily
gestural sign languages have you done
any studies of maybe spatial systems in
sign languages know how they get
represented in the physical
3-dimensional space my lab hasn't done
Studies on sign language but other
people have and they're very they're
very interesting so there are many
different sign languages in the world
and of course sign language is facial in
its nature and that things are
represented actually in space as opposed
to in time the way of spoken languages
and so
there are all kinds of cool decisions
that sign languages also have to make
like am I going to represent left and
right with respect to myself or with
respect to the addressee things like
that and how does that play out well
different sign languages solve that
problem problem differently and that's
huge you have to you have to figure that
out
yeah two versions one version of this
question is Rick bond asks what
experiment would you love to do but
can't and my version that question would
be what ask what questions are you
asking yourself these days in this
subject area so the experiment that
everyone in psychology wants to do but
can't is you get a desert island or a
collection of desert islands and you
perfectly control all the conditions on
these islands and you raise different
groups of children with different
exposure to information either raise
them only with exposure to German or
Spanish or you raise them with
information about their gender or not or
any you can any question that's about
the origins is it nature is it nurture
that's the question that that's the
experiment that everyone wants to do
obviously for silly ethical reasons
can't just go around buying islands and
raising groups of children in which era
which way you want so we have to come up
with other proxies for getting at that
causal story but or finding natural
cases where groups cultural groups
differ and comparing them obviously I
don't actually want to raise children
and controlled conditions on Islands
just to be clear
but the kinds of things that I'm
thinking about now are how we construe
internal experience I think that's the
next set of next set of really
interesting issues because internal
experience how you feel how you think
you know what does it mean to have an
idea when does an idea begin and when
does it end or when you have a thought
how long does a thought last or what
does it mean to understand all of these
internal experiences they're so
important to us and how we construe
ourselves and how we act and very little
is known about what how we come up with
those ideas just that one I think
versus I have a thought which suggests
it was there before versus I created you
have do you have glimmerings on that
hundred different languages doing
internal events differently well if you
have a thought then a thought is is a
noun for one thing right something you
can have other languages would be male
or female itself that's right or it
might be a process it might be something
you do as opposed to something you have
it might be a property of you mm-hmm I
am thinking I'm a thinking person and
there are some really interesting
differences that people have found in
property attribution so here's a study
by one of my colleagues at Stanford Greg
Walton he he and others noticed that if
you express something in terms in terms
of a noun category so you say I am a
carrot eater or I am a chocolate lover
that seems more permanent than if you
say I love carrots or I eat carrots or I
love chocolate and so he thought could
we actually shift people on how much
they think about themselves that they
love carrots or chocolate just by
getting them to write I'm a carrot lover
as opposed to I love carrots so they
brought people in and they told them
this is a handwriting recognition study
just write down this phrase five times
and so people write down this phrase
they think it's a totally arbitrary
phrase half the people are writing I'm a
chocolate lover and half the people are
writing I love chocolate and the people
who are writing I'm a chocolate lover
then later report loving chocolate more
and wanting to buy more chocolate and
eat more chocolate wanting to eat
chocolate at more times in the future
regardless of consequence of
circumstances and so on so these kinds
of little grammatical differences can
have an effect even on how you think of
yourself and so language is certainly
differ and how they describe
personalities for example so some
languages have marvelous noun categories
for personalities Yiddish is famous for
this there's a term in Yiddish for every
personality type you could imagine and a
lot actually a lot of personality terms
in English are borrowed so you can say
someone's a schmuck or their immense
sure there are clucks or a putz and so
on and all of these things are and so
question is is that a more permanent
ascription of personality than you would
have if you used an adjective or if you
used a verb description the interesting
to see whether people who speak
different languages actually think
personalities can change or not
depending on how they express them I see
why you study advertising a lot well
advertise you provide some of the best
examples they're smart folks who are
thinking about how you how you actually
solve that problem people who work in
advertising or never surprise that
language is important for how people can
see the things they think it's bizarre
that anyone would think otherwise are
they reading your stuff and inviting you
to their conferences and things like it
I think they already know it I think
they need me to tell them Lera I have a
question I have a number of questions
here people wondering about gender they
seem oddly attracted to the subject of
gender but here's a good one from Jeff
Jonker who is asking about languages
whether languages have more systems than
just dividing up the categories of nouns
into male and female or some languages
that do male-female and and neuter so
have you looked at languages that are
multi gender or have different other
other ways of construing gender yeah so
lots of languages have the the system
that we talked about masculine feminine
neuter that's a really boring case lots
of languages have much more exciting
ways of dividing up
nouns into gender so some have as many
16 genders there might be a gender for
hunting weapons or shiny things or all
males except canines or something like
that alright there are all kinds of
different categorizations that languages
make my favorite one is what I studied
in college the yaki language and they
have a category four realms squishy
things around squishy things and humans
fall into that category as George Lakoff
famously made one grammatical gender
famous there's an Aboriginal language in
Australia that has a gender for women
fire and dangerous things those are one
one gender most people remember it's a
title of his book but most people
remember that title is women fire and
other dangerous things but in fact
that's not the case it's just women fire
and dangerous things together yet
English used to call hurricanes by
female names now he was a psychologist
was was it a loss or a gain when we went
away from them just female names for
hurricanes I don't I don't care to
speculate but there aren't there are
streaks like that there are streaks like
that in languages so for example in
Hebrew all diseases are feminine so when
a new disease is discovered it's always
going to be feminine why do you think
languages need these categories hmm well
it categories I mean categories are
useful so every word is really a
category right so chair a word like
chair very prosaic word but there are
all these different things that are
chairs they look different they feel
different they smell different all right
and so that word chair is a category and
all all the other words in any language
are two languages in addition to those
word categories also have these
grammatical categories some people study
for example with grammatical gender it's
useful for keeping track of what's
related to what in a sentence so in a
language like Russian you might have you
know dependencies between words that are
seven words apart and it's really hard
to know if this adjective is modifying
this down or
that known and if you have three
grammatical genders that ups the
probability that it will be not so
ambiguous that you'll be able to track
what goes with what
so that's one one useful case but really
we just love to categorize humans love
love putting things in categories and
organizing our world and you look at you
guys are all sitting in these organized
chairs and I've been saying spatially
segregated from you and you're parked
and these wonderfully organized parking
spots outside and our streets are
organized into blocks of it you know
that's that's what we do were wonderful
organizers and language is just as a
masterful case of that trying to create
structure in the world arbitrary or not
arbitrary structure some structure I
think is arbitrary but a lot of it isn't
right so our chairs and tables
arbitrarily masculine or feminine or are
they masculine or feminine in languages
for a particular reason one thing that
we one way we tried to get at that
question was first we compared
grammatical genders across a whole bunch
of different languages European
languages and what we found was there is
a correlation for animal genders so cats
are feminine dogs are masculine
everywhere not everywhere it's just a
correlation but for artifacts we found
no no correlation so it seemed pretty
arbitrary we also asked English speakers
who hadn't learned any grammatical
gender languages to predict we say you
know
chair table can masculine or feminine
and for animals again they were able to
predict but for artifacts they weren't
so there seems to be a whole lot of
arbitrariness one one way to see that is
to see how language how languages
assigned genders to new words that come
into a language borrowed words so my
favorite example is the word giraffe so
Russian and German didn't have a word
for giraffe until relatively recently
for obvious reasons there weren't any
giraffes to talk about and so then the
French go into Africa they see giraffes
they come back with this wonderful new
word giraffe for this mythical creature
in the
and the Germans want to talk about
giraffes too so they borrow the French
word dref now in German it's using the
same spelling of the same alphabet
system as the French there's an e at the
end of the word and so anything within
me at the end is likely to become
feminine in German so giraffe becomes a
feminine word in German Russian uses a
different alphabet system in anything
with a consonant sound and ending gets a
masculine grammatical gender so it
becomes a masculine noun in Russian so
the same word adopted about the same
time into two different languages and
assigned based on these principles of
convenience which was it in French
anybody know lose your ass of course
these I got a question Michael Lyons
could you please speak about relative
vocabularies for example they Eskimos
having 57 words for snow or one I feel
deal with in California Spanish is a
really straightforward relatively simple
language in the sense of one word one
thing and English seems to be just full
of all kinds of workarounds and if I was
going to have Alzheimer's I'd rather
have it in English than in Spanish
because you can always figure out
something that's sort of like what
you're trying to say
well so languages do grow vocabularies
when when a language is spoken in lots
of different locations when a language
is written down when lots of different
professions speak the same language
that's when languages end up with bigger
and bigger vocabularies so you can you
can use those factors to predict how big
a vocabulary language is going to have
Spanish is a very rich language ok sorry
you frown when I said it was simple well
I wouldn't have characterized it that
way um but in in all cases where we
acquire expertise we also acquire
vocabulary right so even and we were
talking about left and right and do we
do it respect to the speaker or the
addressee in some cases you just have to
know so for example if you're a sailor
you don't use left and right on a boat
you use port and starboard because if
you have to say oh wait you're right or
am i right it might be too late
right so you want to avoid any kind of
ambiguity like that so you develop new
new vocabulary to solve that problem
Aboriginal sailors would use the
cardinal points yes they would and
sailors also you know they'd they orient
usually with respect to the wind so the
wind direction is the thing that sets a
lot of things I think so that that's
their kind of richness there's a Co Co
development if you develop vocabulary
for things that you want to talk about
or things you want to think about in
more fine detail but also once that
vocabulary is developed if you're a
child born until language that has that
vocabulary you have to learn it you have
to learn those distinctions and so it
there's kind of this reciprocal set of
relationships people develop more
vocabulary then the next group of folks
who learn the language have to learn
those distinctions and the next the next
group may even refine the vocabulary and
so on but it doesn't go to infinity it
seems like different cultures have a
kind of a that's enough words thanks
women or is that not the case I don't
know we know a lot of words how many
well I don't know how many you know all
right but there's probably some number
English you know the sort of a
college-educated English person will
have X number of words there there are
numbers like that I don't think actually
numbers of words are that meaningful to
count because and in lots of languages
there's even this question of what what
counts as a word so if you speak an
agglutinative language and you can put
lots of different pieces together you
can create what would be a word that's
like you know the eskimo example you can
say snow that's been peed on you know
that's a new word because you can put
all those bits together and it's a 58
words for snow away having that's a
really important category don't boil
that snow there there aren't 58 words
but I think it raises a really the case
of Eskimo snow words I think raises a
very interesting question of what you
count as a word and what makes us say
that one language has a word for
anything so how many words for snow does
English have does it have one word snow
or do we also count slush and sleet and
powder and freshy and skiers have more
words for smell skiers have a lot of
words for snow yeah many different
categories so I have a question about
vocabulary and categories this is this
is prompted by question by Erin Mills
who is asking whether the the
orientation to cardinal directions that
you that you saw among Australian
Aboriginal Australian Aboriginal
languages do you think or do you have
any evidence that that might we know
that a lot of these languages are
rapidly disappearing because people are
shifting to dominant languages there I
guess English so the idea is do these
categorizations survive a shift to
another language it's a it's an
interesting question so what I saw in
Pompeii raw in this community people a
lot of people there speak English but
the whole time I was there I only ever
heard one use of the word right and
never left so when people are giving
directions in English in pond Parral
instead of using left and right they
also don't use north south east and west
but what they do instead is they point
to the correct direction and gesturing
in general in correct directions is very
important people do this all the time so
if someone says oh what are you doing
today you might say oh I'm going to
Melbourne and they might say Oh
Melbourne and they point in a direction
of Melbourne even though it might be
2,000 miles away but that's an important
part of the communication when I first
got there this is something I had this
is a really hard problem I had to solve
I wasn't prepared for which was people
asked where are you from and so somewhat
unusual in there because I'm speaking
with an American accent and that's the
way the television speaks so it wasn't
clear if I had come from the television
or what where where I'd arrived from but
people would say I would say I'm from
California
but that's insufficient you have to
point in the direction from which you've
come and so I had exactly when I had
this problem which way do you point to
California from Cape York do you go
around the way fight went or do you want
go the you know as the bird as the crow
flies or do you go through the earth and
so the first few times I was asked this
question and I was required to point I I
pointed inconsistently and I think
people thought it was quite a shifty
character because I was clearly trying
to hide from them where was it either
either I didn't know which would be very
weird or I was actually not being
straight with them and so they took a
little while for me to settle on a on a
simple simple way of pointing so do you
think this this use of gesture is kind
of an interim strategy and what do you
think their children would do do you
think that they would retain those
gestures or do you think that they would
maybe adopt the English system
altogether or I mean do you see that as
a stage of language and cultural shift
or do you think that those hang on for a
while it's hard to predict I mean there
are lots of things that we do in gesture
that we don't do in language so for
example in English English speakers will
gesture from left to right for time so
you say first we did this then we did
this then we did that but we never say
Tuesday's left of Wednesday
you know I still have lots of things to
do left of the party everything so we
don't use terms left and right to talk
about time
but yet in gesture that's the pattern
that we have so it's conceivable that a
pattern could be very strong injection
and gesture but not exist in in the
language and that would be a way that
interpersonal years in the culture
because long as something else keeps it
alive I've got a couple of limitation
questions Jeremy Faludi says clearly
language shapes thought but what
overrules language for example hungarian
has no gender and pronouns but
hungarians are just as sexist as anyone
else and you nodding your head jason
sbar says do you have any examples of
thoughts or experiences that cannot be
expressed in language and so in a sense
we're leaving for what's the horizon of
this continent that you're exploring so
clearly there are lots of there's lots
of structure in the world that we can
discover even if language doesn't hold
those categories so the case of
Hungarian or Finnish languages that
don't have gender you know it isn't the
case that Finnish speakers are only able
to reproduce by randomly bumping into
each other once in a while an accident
occurs and a new Finnish speaker is born
clearly figured out that there are these
two biological genders all right even
though it's not in the language but even
in cases like that if you look at kids
acquiring these languages this is a
study by Alexandre gora it he did this
study in the 80s I loved this study
he asked kids who are learning Finnish
English and Hebrew the same question he
asked them are you a boy or a girl at
different ages now this is something
kids have to figure out and he had all
kinds of clever ways of asking this that
didn't require using the terms boy and
girl in language so he would have piles
of pictures of boys and girls and he
would you know take all the girls and
put them in one pile and all the boys
and put them in another pile and then he
would take a Polaroid of the kid and say
and here's here's your picture with pile
do you go in and so on what he found was
Hebrew is a very very highly gendered
which even the word for you is gendered
English is kind of an intermediate case
and then Finnish has no gender marking
so what he finds is the hebrew kids get
it first they discover first whether
they themselves are a boy or girl and
then the english kids and then the
finnish case now eventually they all
figure it out more or less right but
there is there is this developmental
difference that it takes you longer to
discover a category if it's if it's not
available in your language so i think
that's that that's kind of a lovely
example of how language can change the
developmental timeline for things that
are not expressible in language there
are lots of things language is really
bad for any kind of spacial things so if
you've ever been at a cake shop and you
want that one no no that one over there
you're keep pointing it's very very hard
to specify exactly which one you want
Aborigines would be cool with that they
just put to the southeast that's right
but there are also lots of quality of
Lake experiences that are hard to
express in language so Vikram Stein had
this wonderful example he says you can
it's very easy to express the height of
Mount Kilimanjaro in language but it's
very hard to express the sound that a
clarinet makes in language how would you
describe the sound of a clarinet that's
a lot harder and so there's some kinds
of things that seem to be much more
suitable for linguistic framing than
other kinds but we have other ways of
representing those we do indeed one more
question from you and one for me and I
think we'll call it a night so I'm gonna
I'm gonna take the project of sitting in
this chair and interject my own question
so this is a follow-up sort of to the
question about what experiment would you
love to do but you can't do and this is
going back to John Brockman's ed
question of 2006 what do you believe
that you cannot prove because you've
proven right or at least tried to prove
or experimented at a number of different
things but what do you believe about
human language that you cannot prove
well I think what I would like to see
my goodness what's very hard to capture
in any one experiment is the set of
relationships between all the different
subsystems of the language so it's one
thing to go in and say well the spatial
system is like this and the temporal
system is like this and the gender
system is like this but all of these
things are actually working together in
any actual natural speaker of a language
they are using all of these things and
so what I would really love to be able
to do is actually start putting those
pieces together and my sense is that
when you're not looking at just one one
little bit at a time but when you're
actually putting a whole system together
much more complex differences emerge
that we right now can't measure yet but
it'll be really exciting to see what it
will take to be able to measure those
system level differences as opposed to
individual experimental example
differences so that's what I'm looking
forward to I don't know how we're gonna
do it but we're gonna try quick
follow-up question do you see the field
of linguistics moving in that direction
a lot of linguistics is turned
experimental in the last 10 years and
also a lot of linguistics has turned
computational in the last 10 years and
that's really exciting because it is
it's just becoming a much more empirical
discipline and I think partially its
that the technology is improving and our
understanding of linguistic differences
is improving and so if you have data to
mine and you know how to mine the data
that it opens up all kinds of questions
you couldn't ask before my question
relates to how as a scientist you sort
of blend and manage your curiosity and
your performance apparatus and so I
guess I would ask you you've gone to
Burning Man several times together
and how did your curiosity and
performance aspects play out and going
to Burning Man and what happened there
well it's I talked I alluded earlier to
learning another languages like
exploring another world finding a new
way
seeing seeing the world of course
another way of exploring another world
is to go to another world so you can
think of you know going to another
country or going even to you don't have
to go to another country you could go to
a neighborhood that's of a different
socioeconomic status than you and see
see a totally different world and I
think Burning Man has that same flavor
of experience for a lot of people where
they feel like they travel to a world
that has a different set of social rules
and a different set of aesthetic
criteria when you go to North Australia
or to Indonesia you don't usually drive
a car shaped like a banana so see a
little about your performance aspects of
Burning Man you know what was that about
and it was it was really just for fun so
in many years ago when I was this tall
some friends and I built this giant
banana vehicle that it was meant to be a
Trojan banana so you would we would all
climb inside and we would go in and
invade another camp and no one would
hurt the banana was such an attractive
thing it was no one would refuse a giant
yellow glowing banana in their camp but
then we would all jump out and attempt
to steal their beer
I feel very confident about the future
of science
yeah
[Music]
you